when i was on dating apps i had guys  interview with my sister before they  could go on a date with me and one guy  took the time to put together a whole  resume objective to obtain permission in  courting pearl davis lists out his  education background bill's competent  cooking skills especially with grilling  tall enough to reach the highest of  shelves amateur jar and bottle opener  dog lover family lover have a door  opener cons i hit my head on doors a lot  moving to san antonio texas late june  clumsy ish good activities working out  dog walking reading watching the latest  trendy movie hiking cooking this man  then lists out his favorite of a bunch  of different stuff